- C'est un don pour le moins
horscococommun qu'a reçu
la Mission Bon Accueil
de Montréal : une cargaison
de pommes  de terre
de l'Île-du-Prince-Érdrdrd
d'une valeur de 15 000 $.
L'histoire commence
quand le généreux donateur,
un Montréalais à la retraite,
entend parler des problèmes
de l'industrie de la pomme de
terre à l'Île-du-Prince-Édouard.
Depuis la fin novembre,
le gouvernement fédéral
interdit l'exportation
vers les États-Unis après
la découverte de la galleveveve,
un champignon qui défigure
les pommes de terre,
mais ne pose aucune menace
pour la santé e.e.e.e.
L'idée lui est venue au beau
milieu de la nuit, raconte-t-il.
Il allait faire livrer plusieurs
milliers de kilos de ces pommes
de terre qui se retrouvaient
soudainement sans marché.
L'initiative a depuis inspiré
un autre donateur : une nouvelle
cargaison aussi imposante
devrait arriver dans
les prochains jours.
Des initiatives réconfortantes
pour le représentant des
producteurs de l'Île-du-Prince-
Édouard. Mais il en faudra
plus pour compenser
les 120 millions de dollars
que devaient représenter
les exportations aux États-Unis
cette année.
MARIE-CLAUDE BIBEAU, ministre
fédérale de l'Agriculture
- Je comprends que c'est
un enjeu majeur pour l'industrie
de la pomme de terre à l'Île-
du-Prince-Édouard, et je vous
assure qu'il n'y a rien qu'on
ne fait pas en ce moment
pour convaincre les Américains
de réouvrir le marché, dans
un premier temps pour la pomme
de terre de table. On sait que
ça va être un peu plus long pour
la pomme de terre de semence.
Il faut faire plus d'analyses.
- Le gouvernement fédéral
a aussi offert une aide
de 28 millions de dollars
à l'industrie. Largement
insuffisant, disent
les producteurs.
Devant l'incertitude, certains
ont décidé de réorienter
temporairement leur entreprise.
Ici, les pommes de terre ont
été remplacées par des boîtes
de tests rapides à assembler.
"C'est une bonne idée,
dit cette employée. Ça nous
donne quelque chose à faire
et on peut aider dans la lutte
contre la COVID."
Si les solutions temporaires
sont les bienvenues,
une véritable sortie de crise
est toujours attendue.
Ici Mathieu Papillo